[Music]
there's all this talk about investing in
medical breakthroughs predominantly
through the National Institute of Health
that's the primary sort of government
agency for medical research what I
caution is fun we all want to live
healthy no that's not even here to
debate but keep in mind that if you take
a tour through a hospital and look at
every machine with an on/off switch that
is brought into the service of
diagnosing the human condition that
machine is based on principles of
physics discovered by a physicist in a
machine designed by an engineer nowhere
in that equation was there a medical
doctor or medical researcher and so you
can't just fund one branch of scientific
inquiry you have to fund them all
because these advances for example the
MRI came from principles of physics
discovered by a physicist who had no
interest in medicine that was in his
point that wasn't what drove him yet it
has this marvelous application that we
could diagnose or at least probe inside
your body without cutting you open first
so the cross-pollination of disciplines
is fundamental to truly revolutionary
advances in our culture and so you can't
fund any one thing without the other
lest you believe you are right on top of
a solution when in fact you're
you
[Music]